the forecast for the tech sector is
Gloom most professional investors in a
Bloomberg survey expect the next move
for tech stocks to be down they see the
NASDAQ 100 as more likely to sink to 10
000 rather than recovering to 14 000.
even so big losses earlier this year may
have exhausted most of the selling a
roughly equal number of respondents say
they plan to buy Tech shares as sell the
shares While most will sit tight here's
Bloomberg technology editor Nate
Langston that gives a sign of of
stability but not a sign that anyone is
preparing to massively get out of tech
or massively jump into it for the first
time this survey also found investors
aren't all that excited about one of the
big new technologies the metaverse vast
majority of his respondents said that
they didn't believe that metaverse was
going to be was going to change how they
do business or interact with with people
over the next two years which suggests
not only that they are familiar with
what the metaverse is but also that
despite knowing what it is they still
don't have confidence in it the issue I
found most interesting in this survey
was the answers around the Green
Technology and the potential benefit it
will have from from the energy crisis in
particular solar and batteries are going
to be of particular interest that
anything that's got exposure to um to
solar panels and and charging is going
to be is going to be beneficial
foreign